(En chantant) L’histoire...
racontée par...
des chaussettes !!!
C'est très marrant.
Un beau jour de printemps préhistorique
Ca a commencé là ? - Oui ça a commencé ! - Pardon
- T'es chiant ! - Je suis désolé !
Un homme préhistorique manquait à l'appel dans la grotte.
Tout le monde s'inquiétait et ils le cherchèrent par monts et par vaux et vallées.
J'avais écrit les textes tout seul, c'est moins marrant
- C'est compliqué !
- Mais oui mais je t'attendais
- Hey
- Il est là!
- Ça va les gars ?
- T'étais où ? - Quoi ? - On t'a cherché partout dans la grotte ! On s'est inquiété !
- Nan mais j'étais allé faire un truc tout seul c'est bon. - Tout seul ?
Mais t'es, mais t'es dingue ou quoi ?
C'est complètement irresponsable!
Avec tout les trucs là, les trucs avec le grandes dents, les trucs avec les moyennes dents!
Les trucs qui font tomber les dents, les... les...
- Non mais j'avais pas envie... euh... de rester dans la grotte ! Ça va !
- Quoi ?
Excuse-moi, eh excuse moi, tu t'es lavé ?
- Non...
- Tu t'es lavé ?
- Non
- Vas-y, je me casse.
- Glork attends, reviens!
- Je sors!
- Je sais bien mais...
- Je me casse.
- Glork attend, s'il te plaît, pars pas!
- Mais pourquoi tu sors tout seul?
- Je...supporte plus la grotte là ça...ça me...Tu trouves pas que ça sent fort à l'intérieur?
- Fort à l'intérieur? Genre?
- Fort tu sais ...oh! Fort quoi!
- Tu peux définir fort?
- Mauvais, ça sent mauvais?
- Non, il faut être plus précis, parce que là je ne comprends pas.
- Oiseau!
(Cri d'oiseau)
- Mauvais, genre l'odeur...
Quand tu commences à manger quelque chose, bah t'as pas envie de le finir tellement ça...
- Non, ça m'arrive jamais ça. Mais après oui c'est vrai qu'il y a une odeur désagréable.
- Surtout depuis que Steve y dort, là depuis un mois, ça sent!
- Mais en plus de Steve.
- Non je vois pas.
- Moi je pense, ça vient du caca plus.
- Ah bah évidemment mais ça après on est obligé!
- Oui-non mais alors je dis pas qu'il faut s'arrêter, je dis qu'il faut s'arrêter, dans la grotte.
- Tu vois?
- Ouais
- Faudrait l'éloigner de nous.
- Par exemple, imagine :
On invente un truc, tu mets ton caca dedans ;
Tu appuies ou tu tires sur quelque chose, et là ton caca il disparaît !
- Wahou !
- Ouais !
- Ça ça serait super !
-Et on pourrait appeler ça : la roue !
- Ou le feu.
- Oiseau !
(cri d'oiseau)
- Ou Snoutch!
- Non Snoutch c'est un pote à moi.
Ok!
- Le benzène!
- Trop long.
- Ouais c'est vrai. Bon, on trouvera. Déjà fabriquons un truc où on fait disparaître le caca en tirant...
- ...Ou en poussant!
- Oui!
- Les 2 sont possibles.
- Mais en même temps, inventer ça, c'est pas facile hein!
Déjà, techniquement je sais même pas parler, on se comprend par des gestes et des cris.
- Sinon, on fait un trou au fond de la grotte.
- Ah ben voilà !
- Et on appelle ça la roue !
- Ou la poudre...
- Excellent !
- Merci !
- Ou l'uranium enrichi ?
- Et on fera tous caca dans l'uranium enrichi.
- Ah mais il y a un problème...
- Pourquoi ?
- Si deux personnes ont envie en même temps....
- Eh ben... Bah c'est rien on dit : Ils doivent se battre à mort et le survivant il peut aller à l'uranium enrichi.
- Ou y'en a un qui se retient et qui attend son tour.
- Ah c'est horrible ! Se retenir? Mais t'as pas d'cœur ! Nan le combat à mort c'est plus simple.
- Moi ça me va, je trouve ça bien.
- Ok.
- Génial! On note tout ça.
- Avec plaisir, mais je sais pas noter. Je sais pas écrire, je sais pas ce qu'écrire signifie.
- Moi non plus.
- Alors on retient tout ça de tête et on va le dire aux autres.
- Voilà! Aucune chance.
- Ouais, moi pareil, j'ai pas de mémoire.
- Bon! Et ben on aura bien passé le temps quand même hein!
- Ah carrément!
- Moi je trouve. Et c'est ainsi que pas grand chose s'est passé.
- Mais on a bien passé le temps quand même.
- En tout cas, d'après des chaussettes.
- Oiseau! Hahaha! Je t'ai eu! T'as un gage!
...Ok ça vaut.